[Música]
último bloque de economía en directo
américa ya está conmigo en el estudio
jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
nuevamente hablemos de everbank porque
pago ya finalmente parte de su deuda no
así es y según fuentes vinculadas a
bloomberg hizo un pago de al menos 84
millones de dólares esto como un abono a
todos estos intereses que debe de una
deuda enorme que tiene esta inmobiliaria
el pago lo hizo subir las acciones de
los bonos de la inmobiliaria las
acciones del gigante endeudado subieron
un 4,7 por ciento en hong kong mientras
los llamados bonos basuras asiáticos
también aumentaron este pago raúl ofrece
un alivio temporal para every rain y le
da la oportunidad de vender activos y
recaudar algo más de efectivo para
saldar su deuda con acreedores y
proveedores la deuda total es de 300 mil
millones de dólares y representa el 2%
del producto interno bruto de china de
esto unos 37 mil millones de dólares
corresponde a préstamos por devolver que
tiene que cumplir antes de finales de
junio del 2022 evergrande verá a pagar
la próxima semana también otros 40 y 75
millones de dólares y ayer la
inmobiliaria volvió a cotizar en la
bolsa de hong kong pues de más de dos
semanas de suspensión donde registra una
caída del 12,5 por ciento borge y
francia hará un bono a los hogares más
pobres cuéntenos por qué el anuncio lo
hizo el primer ministro francés y dijo
que los hogares de menores ingresos para
recibir cien euros del gobierno para
ayudarlos a soportar el impacto del
aumento de los precios de la energía y
la gasolina este pago llamado pago de
inflación se dará a los ciudadanos que
ganen menos de dos mil euros netos al
mes y le costará al gobierno unos
4.420 millones de dólares el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón ha dicho que
busca limitar el daño de su historial
económico afectado por la escalada de
los precios de la energía el gobierno
francés también busca ayudar a los
pobres a pagar las facturas de la
calefacción a propósito de la llegada
del invierno los impuestos sobre la
energía y la gasolina pueden ser un tema
delicado en francia- que ya antes han
derivado en varias manifestaciones el
pago de los cien euros se va a dar en
las nóminas de los trabajadores privados
a partir de diciembre mientras que los
públicos y algunos jubilados lo van a
recibir a partir de enero próximo jorge
y el fondo monetario internacional les
brindó datos para américa latina' cuales
a nuestros datos bueno no son tan
positivos el organismo dice que la
región va a tardar al menos cinco años
para recuperar los niveles económicos
que tenía antes de la pandemia nigel
shuar director interino del departamento
del hemisferio occidental del fmi
aseguró que la expectativa de
crecimiento para la región se ubica en
6,3 por ciento para 2021 y el 3% para el
2022 el funcionario agregó que los
países de la región deben prepararse
para que esta recuperación no sea un
camino lineal y anticipen un camino
largo y sinuoso con la ayuda de la
pandemia de latinoamérica la economía se
contrajo un 7% por encima de la media
global que fue el 3,1 por ciento lo que
provocó el aumento de la pobreza y
afectó directamente la clase media
también sostuvo que los progresos
económicos van a depender del ritmo de
la vacunación en latinoamérica raúl el
41% de la población está vacunada pero
aún persisten grandes disparidades en
algunos países que no llegan a inmunizar
en el 20% de su población escuchemos lo
que dijo
pequeñita buenas noticias que después de
cobrar un precio muy alto en 2021 la
pandemia parece estar retrocediendo en
muchas partes de américa latina y el
caribe sin embargo este no es un momento
para celebrar las jornadas de vacunación
han ayudado a mitigar el impacto de la
pandemia pero aún existen importantes
desigualdades en la disponibilidad de
vacunas y es necesario abordar las de
villiers porque vamos ahora con los
indicadores económicos arrancamos en
wall street donde el índice de
tecnologías nazca de abrió en negativo
luego de que el fabricante de chips
intel advirtiera sobre márgenes de
ganancias más bajos en asia las acciones
tecnológicas subieron animadas por sus
pares estadounidenses mientras que las
acciones inmobiliarias chinas repuntaron
tras el pago de intereses de ever ground
este pago de intereses también crea un
efecto positivo en las bolsas europeas y
para finalizar que nuestra cifra el día
así vamos a hablar ahora de la inflación
interanual de méxico que superó las
expectativas en la primera quincena de
octubre y se ubicó por encima del
objetivo oficial
6,12 por ciento alimentando la tensión
sobre el banco central de que suba por
cuarta ocasión consecutiva su tasa de
interés referencial en noviembre próximo
jorge gracias por toda la información
económica volamos directamente hasta
parís
[Música]